clean code is code that is readable
reusable and respectable I'm going to
show you how to write clean code and
objects and data structures this video
is part of the series I'm doing based on
an article by Ryan McDermott on clean
code and JavaScript
check the description for a link to the
original article when creating an object
it's better to use getters and setters
to access data instead of just looking
for a property on an object this is
going to make it easier to change your
program later it makes adding
validations easier
it gives increased encapsulation on your
object and a few other benefits so look
let's look at this code right here
we have the function make bank account
and when you are creating an object like
this whatever you return is what you're
going to be able to access in the object
so here we instantiate an bank account
object and called account and then we're
going to see it start with a balance of
zero whenever you make a banking object
but we're going to then set it to 100
and then we can console that log that
and you will see that the balance is now
100 when it started as zero that's the
bad way to do it where there's no getter
and setter you can just directly access
the property in the object now let me
show you the good way we are going to
create a variable here and set to zero
anything that's up here that's not in
the return statement is private so
you're not gonna be able directly access
this variable now and now we're going to
create a function here and another
function and then we are going to return
just the functions so I've created a
getter function get balance and a setter
functions set balance and then I've only
returned the function you see I did not
return the actual property or variable
balance we've only returned the
functions that means these are the only
things you're going to be able to access
in the object anything under the return
is what is publicly available to access
an object so you can still get the
balance by calling this function and
it's going since this function is is
going to be inside the object it can
still access that variable inside the
object
and we can also set the balance by doing
balance equals amount okay first I'm
actually gonna change these two commas
semicolons to comment that doesn't need
it on there it was a mistake having the
semicolon so account that balance
instead of account that balance we're
gonna do account that set balance to 100
and we're gonna X instead of making it
equals 100 we're gonna pass in 100 and
then we're gonna do account that get
balance to get the balance and it still
says 100 so that is a better way of
doing it using getters and setters the
next thing I'm going to talk about is
that you should make objects have
private members so here's the
constructor function for an employee
object this constructor function
actually creates the initial object
prototype but we can add another
property to the prototype and this one
down here is a function so we create the
employee object but we're gonna add to
the prototype a get name function where
it's gonna return this name so remember
this is actually the bad way to do it
whenever you use the word this and dot
and then you put a property named after
it this dot name this is creating a
basically a public property that can be
directly accessed so this is not this is
not really a private member this is a
public member when you use this dot name
so let's see how this works I'm going to
uncomment this out let me put some
parentheses on there and if we run that
it's gonna say employ name John Doe
employee name undefined so let's go
through this code here we are going to
instantiate a new employee object and
call employee and we're gonna pass in
the name John Doe so it's gonna go to
this function up here it's gonna it's
gonna do this that name equals name then
the name we passed in was John Doe
then we're gonna console dialogue now
these are template literals just look in
the description of this video to see a
link to my other video about template
literals so we have employ name and
we're gonna do employ dot get name so
we're calling this get named function
now then we're gonna delete employ that
name and if you cancel that log employee
that get name again it's going to say
undefined so this is the bad way of
creating properties and members of an
object because it's easy
to do something like the deleting it or
you can change the name really easily we
want to make it a little harder to
change the name so basically I'm going
to delete this whole section here and we
are not even going to use the this dot
notation because that creates a public
property that can be easily accessed and
deleted so we're gonna do this so we're
passing in a name but we're not
assigning it to a property so it's still
stored in the object but it's private so
it cannot be directly accessed but we
can't access it using this function
that's returned we're returning the get
name function that's going to return the
name variable that's with an object but
it's not a property of the object so
let's look at this down here now we're
again to create a new employee called
employee we got passing the name John
Doe and we're gonna call get name let me
just run it this and we'll see how it's
different so you can see look employ
name John Doe employ name John Doe
remember the last time the second name
was undefined but when we try to delete
employee dot name well there actually is
no employee dot name we not create that
property in the function so this is
going to be a better way to create
object so the members are private and
you can't accidentally delete it or
change it directly you can only do it
through the functions well thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good